si américa latina' no está envuelta en
alguna crisis es que no es américa
latina' pobreza desigualdad golpes de
estado revueltas movimientos populistas
que surgen hasta debajo de las piedras
recuentos dudosos la lista es larga muy
larga sin embargo si algo parece estable
pero muy pero que muy estable en estas
regiones todo aquello que respecta a su
integridad territorial pero y si os
dijéramos que existe un conflicto que se
ha ido cocinando a fuego lento y que
ahora podría literalmente partir en dos
el conosur queréis saber exactamente de
qué estamos hablando pues atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero antes quiero haceros un anuncio muy
especial estamos en año de mundial así
que hemos querido preparar algo super
novedoso que creemos que os va a
encantar la liga visual político
[Música]
de la mano de nuestros amigos de wenger
hemos puesto en marcha una liga fantasy
donde podremos competir entre todos
participar en la liga visual política es
muy sencillo y por supuesto totalmente
gratuito y además podréis conseguir un
montón de premios simplemente tenéis que
seguir el enlace que os dejamos en los
comentarios y la descripción y una vez
que descarguéis la app de wenger si es
que no la tenéis ya este os llevará
directamente a nuestra liga entonces es
tan sólo tendréis que asignar un nombre
a vuestro equipo y listo ya estaréis
preparados para gestionar vuestro propio
equipo y enfrentaros a fonseca alberto y
a mí tendréis que ver qué jugadores
fichase qué jugadores vendéis preparar
la alineación en el sistema y escoger a
vuestro capitán luego en función de los
resultados reales tendréis más o menos
puntos confías en la nueva apuesta de
laporta y la camioneta 2.0 y crees que
elevando esquí se va a salir crees que
este será en cambio el año de valverde y
los hermanos william en el athletic
piensas que carleto seguirá su racha
triunfal y que jugadores como benzema
modric o cross seguirán al máximo nivel
pues ya sabéis lo que tenéis que hacer
pero dicho esto arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas como todos sabéis
chile y argentina son los dos países más
meridionales esto es situados más al sur
de toda américa latina' ambos
independizaron del reino de españa a
inicios del siglo 19 así que ellas suman
más de 200 años de trayectoria solitario
claro que esa no es toda la historia sus
territorios hoy comprenden espacios y
jurisdicciones y antiguamente estaban
ocupadas por distintas comunidades
indígenas entre ellas los mapuches un
pueblo originario de américa del sur
radicado en el centro de chile y en el
sur de argentina en lo que hoy se conoce
como la auracanía chilena y la patagonia
argentina pues bien el caso es que si
hasta ahora esta etnia había vivido en
paz tanto con los argentinos como con
los chilenos eso ahora ha cambiado los
últimos años se han caracterizado por
una escalada de la violencia que incluso
ha obligado al gobierno de chile a
militarizar parte del país concretamente
desde el año 2009 a algunos grupos
mapuches muy radicalizados mantienen una
creciente y abierta lucha contra los
estados de chile y argentina- por el
control del territorio
dado que no ha existido ninguna señal
del gobierno de poner fin a las fuerzas
represivas en nuestras comunidades hemos
tomado una decisión como coordinadora
mapuche arauco malleco manifestamos
públicamente nuestra renuncia a la
nacionalidad chilena y declaramos
territorio de la nación autónoma mapuche
comunicado público en 2009 de la
coordinadora mapuche arauco malleco este
comunicado supuso la punta de lanza de
la crisis actual ahora bien en qué
consiste en las reclamaciones mapuches
que las ha motivado hasta qué punto
peligra la integridad territorial de
chile y de la argentina pues amigos
amigas en este vídeo vamos a responder a
todas estas preguntas pero para entender
cómo se ha llegado hasta esta situación
antes antes tenemos que ver un poco de
historia
[Música]
ah
ingredientes para el conflicto
para conocer dónde comenzó el problema
tenemos que remontarnos hasta el siglo
19 en aquel momento la sociedad mapuche
estaba construida sobre un complejo
sistema de alianzas matrimoniales entre
las familias más poderosas pero como se
definía el poder de cada grupo pues
fundamentalmente por su capacidad
ganadera y especialmente por su
capacidad para relacionarse con las
fuerzas coloniales en este sentido los
mapuches eran un grupo poco centralizado
en lo que respecta a sus relaciones de
poder de hecho la propia concepción de
un pueblo mapuche se suele interpretar
como una construcción básicamente
occidental esto es así porque en
realidad esta comunidad indígena era muy
heterogénea lo que resultaría clave en
distintas etapas pero por ahora no nos
desviemos
con la independencia de chile y
argentina- entre los años 1810 y 1818
surgió un nuevo escenario para las
relaciones políticas con los mapuches
quienes a partir de ese momento tuvieron
que acostumbrarse a negociar con los
nuevos gobiernos nacionales el problema
fundamental es que estos gobiernos
tenían el objetivo de forjar consolidar
y cuestionar sentimientos de nación en
los territorios independizados es decir
se enfrentaban a la tarea de construir
el concepto de nación chilena y nación
argentina pues bien para cumplir con
dicho objetivo era esencial integrar
tres conceptos clave sociedad estado y
territorio sin embargo tras echar a la
corona española los gobiernos de las
nuevas repúblicas se se dieron cuenta de
que gran parte de su teórico dominio
territorial se encontraba erosionado por
las jurisdicciones bajo control de
comunidades indígenas como los mapuches
comunidades que de hecho y tal y como
podéis ver controlaban la mayor parte
del nuevo territorio libre en otras
palabras que para los políticos de la
época estos grupos suponían un claro
impedimento para su proyecto de
construcción nacional
durante la mitad del siglo 19 ambas
repúblicas ya habían avanzado desde su
capital hacia el sur sumando cada vez
más y más terreno para su proyecto
político
o un proceso que no fue regular sino que
se fue dando de forma intermitente por
el constante surgimiento de diferentes
conflictos internos el caso es que de
esta forma durante la segunda mitad del
siglo 19 el estado chileno ya mucho más
organizado se vio con la capacidad más
que suficiente como para publicar en
1866 un decreto que establecía que todas
las tierras sobre las que no se pudiera
comprobar una ocupación mapuche efectiva
y ojo continuada por el período de un
año pasarían a ser considerados como
terrenos baldíos y el estado procedería
a subastarlos comenzó así una cruzada
militar conocida como la ocupación del
albacán ya en ese momento gran parte de
las comunidades mapuche se pasaron al
lado argentino para evitar ser
alcanzadas por las tropas chilenas pero
amigos a migrar su tranquilidad duró
poco en 1878 el estado argentino puso en
marcha un proceso similar al de chile
con la conocida como conquista del
desierto una operación a gran escala que
había sido precedida por operativos
similares en el sur de la provincia de
buenos aires
[Música]
tras estas dos campañas los mapuches
pasaron de ocupar 10 millones de
hectáreas a haberse concentrado en poco
más de 500 mil es decir perdieron el 95
por ciento del terreno que controlaban y
desde luego por el camino sufrieron
muchas bajas aunque este respecto hay
que decir que las estimaciones de los
diferentes historiadores actuales varían
mucho
tras llevarse a cabo estas dos campañas
políticos militares tanto el estado
argentino como el chileno dieron por
solventada la cuestión territorial y
comenzaron a construir un estado moderno
bajo el principio de gobernar es poblar
de esta forma se generaron los
incentivos suficientes como para atraer
en europa una enorme cantidad de
inmigrantes que cambiarían por completo
la realidad local por ejemplo se estima
que en el año 1920 casi la mitad la
mitad de todos los habitantes de buenos
aires javier nacido en el exterior y
claro eso era algo que cambiaba por
completo la situación política
[Música]
en el siglo 20 bajo la alfombra
durante comienzos del siglo 20 los
mapuches diezmados en el mapa con una
sociedad nueva de inmigrantes europeos
una economía próspera y un mundo
dominado por el conflicto el asunto
indígena ha desaparecido por completo de
la agenda pública aunque por supuesto
eso no significa que la realidad mapuche
y sus reivindicaciones
desaparecieran por completo
poco a poco la situación económica y
política se fue complicando en ambos
países de la inestabilidad de mediados
de siglo se pasó a los golpes militares
de los años 70 lo que dio paso a la
dictadura militar de jorge rafael videla
y sus secuaces en la argentina ya la de
augusto pinochet chile y fue
precisamente la dictadura chilena quien
en 1976 creó el consejo regional mapuche
como un órgano asesor para favorecer el
vínculo del estado con la población
indígena de la araucanía chilena el tema
mapuche volvía a estar sobre la mesa
y de hecho esta región la auracanía
chilena fue una de las dos únicas
regiones de todo chile donde el
plebiscito que desplazó a pinochet el
poder le fue favorable al dictador pero
sea como sea lo cierto es que a partir
de mediados del siglo 20 volvieron a
registrarse protestas actos
reivindicativos y redadas que en cierto
modo podemos considerar como el embrión
de la situación actual por ejemplo entre
los años 50 60 y 70 se produjeron
acciones de resistencia contra la
construcción de represas y los programas
de explotación agrícola esto ocurrió
especialmente en el centro de chile
[Música]
con todo la llegada de la democracia
chile y argentina- entre los 80 y los 90
dio pie a que surgieran nuevas
instituciones estatales para intentar
establecer vínculos más estrechos con
las comunidades indígenas por ejemplo en
1985 se creó en la argentina el
instituto nacional de asuntos indígenas
y en 1992 se fundó en santiago la
corporación nacional de desarrollo
indígena
así que aunque el conflicto no fuera
estrictamente visible lo cierto es que
la llama ya estaba prendida claro que he
visto lo visto no parece que estas
organizaciones lograrán sus objetivos
pero sea como sea así es como llegamos
al siglo 21 un periodo de tiempo donde
ahora sigue el conflicto mapuche se ha
puesto al rojo vivo atentos
[Música]
estalla el conflicto
la historia de los mapuches es mucho más
compleja pero creo que con todo lo que
hemos visto tenemos más que suficiente
para comprender los orígenes del
problema al menos sus claves principales
nos parece pues bien ahora que ya
estamos situados estamos preparados para
viajar hasta el año 2009 el año en el
que se produce la declaración de guerra
queridos amigos amigas son muchas las
comunidades mapuches que no se sienten
ni argentinas ni chilenas sino que para
ellas ambos estados significan
exactamente lo mismo la represión contra
sus ancestros y en cierto modo su
cultura y modo de vida creo que aquí
tenemos que hacer dos apuntes
importantes ni todos los mapuches han
asumido un clima belicista ni la
situación en chile en argentina son
plenamente equiparables
[Música]
según el censo poblacional de chile del
2017 aproximadamente 17 millones de
personas en este país se declararon
pertenecientes al pueblo mapuche esto
supone aproximadamente el 10 por ciento
de la población total del país por su
parte en argentina el peso mapuche es
mucho más reducido hablamos de
aproximadamente 205 mil personas que se
auto reconocen como mapuche en todo el
país apenas un 0,5 por ciento de la
población argentina
por supuesto no hay casi dos millones de
personas alzadas en armas contra el
gobierno chileno y el argentino al menos
hoy por hoy porque si así fuese la
historia sería totalmente diferente pero
recordáis que los mapuches no solían
organizarse bajo un liderazgo
centralizado pues exactamente eso mismo
sigue ocurriendo hoy en día así que no
no existe una entidad que los engloba a
todos y los personas de tomar parte en
la resistencia armado
de hecho de los cientos y cientos de
miles casi dos millones de chilenos
argentinos que se identifican como
mapuches sólo una fracción milita en
agrupaciones violentas es decir la
inmensa mayoría de las personas que
forman parte de esta comunidad convive
de forma pacífica e interactúan con las
instituciones nacionales esto es algo
muy importante que debemos de tener en
cuenta para evitar errores de
interpretación o que se estigmatiza como
violento a todo el pueblo mapuche
[Música]
de hecho si algo nos dice de la
evidencia histórica es precisamente que
estigmatizar y etiquetar a todo un
pueblo suele ser la mejor forma de
empujarlo a la radicalidad
[Música]
el caso es que con el paso del tiempo
han surgido movimientos bien organizados
y armados que han provocado la actual
espiral de violencia este es el caso por
supuesto de la conocida como
coordinadora mapuche arauco malleco pero
no es el único en 2014 también surgió la
resistencia ancestral mapuche con un
comunicado que dio la señal de alarma en
la región no queremos integrarnos
queremos liberarnos ni argentinos ni
chilenos somos nación mapuche todo el
territorio libre y recuperado para todo
nuestro pueblo resistencia ancestral
mapuche recordáis las campañas llevadas
a cabo por los ejércitos chilenos y
argentinos que consideraron a los
mapuches un problema común pues parece
cara la historia regresa en forma de
boomerang de hecho el 31 de mayo del
2022 la cámara de diputados de chile
declaró a las organizaciones que veis en
pantalla como asociaciones ilícitas de
carácter terrorista la cámara de
diputados- declara las organizaciones
coordinadora arauco malleco resistencia
mapuche malleco resistencia mapuche
lafkenche wichan mapu como asociaciones
ilícitas de carácter terrorista y
requiere de su excelencia el presidente
de la republica su persecución penal de
conformidad con lo dispuesto en la ley
número 18.314 sobre conductas
terroristas resolución 135 del 31 de
mayo de 2022 pero ahora bien exactamente
en qué consiste la liberación mapuche
qué territorio reivindican hoy en día
concretamente con qué argumentos
justifican la acción armada
pues bien lo que busca liberar y
recuperar estas agrupaciones se conoce
como wall mapu y comprende el centro
tanto de chile como en argentina
dividiendo por tanto ambos países
literalmente por la mitad de hecho la
propia capital chilena estaría dentro de
este territorio os imagináis a estos dos
países partidos literalmente por la
mitad hacia chile trasladando su capital
no la verdad pues hay quienes han tomado
las armas para conseguirlo de momento se
trata de un nivel de violencia no muy
alto pero que tiende a ser más o menos
constante por ejemplo para el 2017 la
situación había devenido en una espiral
de violencia sin precedentes que obligó
a los gobiernos de mauricio macri y
michelle bachelet a empezar a poner en
marcha planes conjuntos para combatir
los focos de violencia luego el propio
sebastián piñera ganador de las
elecciones ese mismo año en chile
prometió mano dura y la aplicación de la
ley antiterrorista
[Música]
y es que amigos amigas podemos decir que
el conflicto empezó así
microempresarios dueños de camiones
quemados en la araucanía
quedamos arruinados y aterrorizados en
enero de 2013 el conflicto mapuche
enciende chile
noviembre de 2014 el grupo mapuche se
adjudicó incendios en bariloche y
declaró la guerra a chile y argentina-
que continuó de esta forma el 8 de
octubre de 2017 piñera aseguró que la
coordinadora arauco malleco es
terrorista y está financiada desde el
exterior
20 de julio de 2018 mauricio macri sobre
el conflicto mapuche nadie puede creer
que está por encima de la ley 25 de
septiembre de 2018 si le anuncia un plan
para apaciguar a las minorías mapuches y
que actualmente nos encontramos tal que
así 18 de julio de 2022 chile 20
vehículos quemados en nuevo ataque en
conflicto mapuche tras nuevos ataques de
grupos radicales mapuches empresarios y
legisladores chilenos exigen extender el
despliegue militar
la violencia previsiblemente va a
escalar en la zona mapuche salvador-
milla leo experto en el conflicto
mapuche y ex asesor de gabriel boric por
si no fuera suficiente el movimiento
mapuche ha ido poco a poco adquiriendo
un cierto tinte anticapitalista para
hacerse con el apoyo de los movimientos
de la izquierda latinoamericana fijados
el control territorial debe ser
entendido como un proceso de carácter
autonomista en relación al estado y a
sus instituciones y anticapitalistas en
enero de 2019 comunicado de la
coordinadora arauco maipú así que ahora
la lucha por recuperar el territorio
mapuche es también una lucha contra el
neoliberalismo y el capitalismo
internacional ver para creer pero claro
entre 2019 y 2021 los gobiernos de estos
dos países pasaron a estar dominados
precisamente por políticos de izquierdas
así que la pregunta es qué pensáis que
hicieron pues atentos
sorpresa en el estadio mano dura desde
la izquierda
hubo un momento en el que parecía que
los gobiernos de izquierda podrían
llegar a pactar con los grupos mapuches
el problema es que aunque estos sean
escorado ideológicamente hacia la
izquierda su principal reivindicación
sigue chocando frontalmente con la
propia configuración estatal de estos
países incluso podríamos decir con la
mismísima existencia de chile y
argentina- al menos tal y como hoy los
conocemos y eso eso es lo que explica
noticias como este 16 de mayo de 2022
gabriel boric volvió a militarizar el
sur de chile ante el aumento de la
violencia el 20 de mayo de 2022 el
gobierno chileno advirtió que las
fuerzas armadas responderán si son
atacadas durante el estado de emergencia
en el sur junio de 2022 renuevan por un
nuevo período el estado de excepción en
la araucanía y provincias de arauco y
bío bío para la sorpresa de muchos el
presidente de izquierda chileno gabriel
boric ha decidido continuar e incluso
impulsar la política de mano dura de
sebastián piñera lo que por cierto
parece chocar con sus propias palabras
del 11 de marzo el día en que fue
investido presidente cuando dijo
exactamente esto lo que sucede en la
araucanía es un conflicto entre el
estado chileno y un pueblo que tiene
derecho a existir y la solución no es ni
será la violencia gabriel boric
president de chile desde entonces el
cambio no ha podido ser más radical si
se quieren utilizar esas demandas de los
pueblos indígenas para enfrascar o
disfrazar el crimen organizado el
narcotráfico u otros eventos delictivos
nuestro gobierno va a ser claro enfático
y no va a descansar en perseguir y
encontrar a los responsables y dizque a
sitges ministra del interior de chile
pero vale esta es la situación en chile
pero que está ocurriendo en la argentina
pues digamos que envueltos en mil crisis
y con un gobierno partido en mil pedazos
no parece que el presidente fernández
pues tenga tiempo para esta cuestión
creo que el problema en argentina es
como hemos visto mucho más pequeño que
en chile afecta a 20 veces menos
porcentaje de la población así que
mientras las cosas no se salgan de madre
en el otro lado pues digamos que parece
que se lo pueden permitir aunque esto
por supuesto de santiago de chile- no
haga ninguna gracia queridos amigos
amigas para muchos analistas de no
cambiar las tornas la actual situación
en torno al conflicto mapuche puede ser
el antecedente a una espiral de
violencia mucho pero que mucho mayor que
puede llegar a provocar un shock inédito
en la historia de américa del sur pero
llegados hasta aquí turno para ti sabías
que argentina y sobre todo chile
enfrentaba en semejante el problema
territorial como piensas que pueden
resolver esta situación crees que
llegará el día en el que ambos países
pierdan el control sobre esta parte del
territorio qué opinión te merece este
conflicto pues déjanos por aquí abajo
vuestros comentarios y abramos debate y
por supuesto así es tenidos a resulta
interesante no olvidéis darle like y
suscribiros a visual política y ahora
también apuntaros a la liga visual
política una vez más muchas gracias por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]